a fight almost broke at yesterday during
a senate hearing and this is Republican
senator Mark Wayne Mullen pretends like
he's self-made what a clown fraud always
has been always will be quit the tough
guy act in these Senate hearings you
know where to find me any place anytime
Cowboy sir this is a time this is a
place if you want to run your mouth we
can be to consenting adults we can
finish it here okay that's fine perfect
you want to do it now I'd love to do it
right now well stand your butt up then
you stand your butt up oh hold stop it
is that your solution every p no no sit
down sit down you know you're a United
States Senator sit okay when I saw the
the you know kind of the description of
the thumbnail of this video is going
viral on Twitter I thought it was like a
Heat of the Moment they're arguing back
and forth and the C you want to take
this outside which would already be
really funny and great but no this was
planned like he printed out the tweets
and he was ready